So the truth is that the class movie
can contain whatever we want it to contain. And
in this case, I will pick the movie's
title, its youtube_trailer, its reviews, the storyline and its
poster_image. Now that decision will mean, that if
I said something like toy_story.storyline. The program will print
this. A story of a boy and his toys that come to life, and if I said,
avatar.show_trailer, the program would play avatar's YouTube
trailer. So, in summation, when designing the class
Movie, we probably want to remember data like
the movie's title, its storyline, its poster image,
and the link to its YouTube trailer. And one thing we may want to do
with this data, is to have a show
trailer function which opens the movie's YouTube trailer.
Okay, let's turn this design, into code.